bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct se ravit de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir ensemble c'est le nom
de la nouvelle confédération qui
regroupe les différentes composantes de
la majorité ses ténors se sont mises en
ordre de marche pour les législatives
cet après-midi le modem obtient une
centaine de circonscriptions horizon le
parti d'edouard philippe une soixantaine
de quoi assurer un groupe à l'assemblée
aux différentes sensibilités décryptage
sur ce plateau dans un instant avec nos
invités et s'ils coûtent in déclaré
officiellement la guerre le 9 mai
prochain
deux grands témoins ce soir pour évoquer
la situation en ukraine le général
trinquant pour nous aider à comprendre
ce qui se joue sur le terrain notamment
à mario paul ville martyre et puis
isabelle lasserre du figaro ancienne
correspondante à moscou à la veille des
grandes commémorations de la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale en russie enfin
nous trouverons nous affranchit pour eux
leur parti pris ce soir il sert verdi se
projette sur le discours que doit
prononcer emmanuel macron au parlement
européen de strasbourg lundi prochain et
puis à 20 ce jeu nous parlera de la
rupture ou sommet entre paris et bamako
le mali qui déchire les accords de
défense qui viennent aux deux pays voilà
pour le menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
et
bienvenue à vous chers téléspectateurs
merci beaucoup d'être au rendez-vous
bonsoir pierre-alexandre anglade bonsoir
ravis de vous accueillir alors vous êtes
toujours porte parole du groupe en
marche alors qui va devenir renaissance
si j'ai bien compris pour cette campagne
des législatives
vous représentez dans la même
circonscription du benelux que je
belgique pays bas luxembourg vous avez
été réinvestis voilà on aura la liste en
quelques instants ça m'a l'air bien
parti justement cette liste on l'attend
d'un moment à l'autre dans soir elsa
reçoit les amendes un gars va vous avez
suivi la conférence de presse des barons
de la majorité cet après-midi et puis
vous avez quelques petites infos sur
cette liste des première investiture on
attend une 2 200 plus d'une centaine ses
environs je regarde mon téléphone c'est
pas par un politesse et qu'on nous
promet qu'elle va arriver c'est imminent
mais on les fait rêver hier d'être sur
le coup en direct bonsoir et hejira
formule merci d'être là rédacteur en
chef société à l'express je vous donne
la parole à tous les trois pour ce
décryptage sur lcp des d investiture de
la majorité mais d'abord cet attelage
ensemble on va le voir en images ferrand
guérini bayrou et philippe sur une même
estrade ça n'est pas si fréquent
l'objectif c'était de donner évidemment
le coup d'envoi tout sourire des
législatives nicolas quoi d'où
la naissance d'une confédération
législatives un mariage de raison un
nouveau nom pour la république en marche
et un peu d'autosatisfaction
jeu rouler dans la bonne humeur
et
face à un parterre de journalistes
françois bayrou edouard philippe richard
ferrand et stanislas guérini ont
esquissé les contours de ce qu'il
souhaite être la future majorité
présidentielle une confédération dont le
nom est déjà tout trouvé ensemble de
maître mot unité et pluralisme ensemble
c'est le rassemblement la volonté d'être
soudés d'être côte à côte pour porter
le projet les valeurs les idées des
manuels macro et nous n'accepterons pas
de dissidence sans grande surprise elle
sera donc composé du modem d'horizon le
parti d'edouard philippe et de la
république en marche ou plutôt de
renaissance nouveau nom du parti
présidentiel
dévoilé en avant première par son
délégué général nous allons et nous
lançons aujourd'hui nous initions
aujourd'hui un mouvement de refondation
de la république en marche pour pouvoir
continuer à élargir à refonder ce
mouvement politique a créé le président
de la république et vallées macron il ya
peu plus de six ans maintenant un accord
de circonstance pour soutenir le
président de la république
officiellement aucune dissension dans
les troupes tous les partis semblent
satisfaire venu
conclure un bon accord
un bon accord qui permet de construire
une majorité stable
solide je l'espère diverses qui pourra
en travaillant sérieusement mettre en
oeuvre les engagements qui ont été pris
par le président la république au vent
de la campagne il est convenu que chacun
des partis politiques aura droit à son
propre groupe parlementaire mais avant
cela il faudra faire élire suffisamment
de députés sous cette nouvelle bannière
commune alors le mot deux jours cette
confédération si j'ai bien compris car
alexandre drague c'est des petites
chapelles qui coexistent ou des grosses
chapelle on peut le dire les unes à côté
des autres c'est bien ça ensemble mais
chacun de son côté ce sont des partis
politiques qui incarnent des courants de
la vie politique française qui sont
engagés pour certains aux côtés du
président de la république maintenant
depuis plus de cinq ans et qui ont
vocation à travailler encore ensemble
dans les années à venir et à mener une
campagne législative pour essayer
d'offrir au président de la république
la majorité la plus large partie
pourquoi renoncer au parti unique le mot
l'expression avait été prononcée même le
soir même du premier tour par emmanuel
macron mais je crois que c'est important
de pouvoir faire vivre dans une dans une
architecture commune les différentes
sensibilités qui peuvent exister au sein
de la majorité et le modem de françois
bayrou n'a pas la même histoire que
horizon d'edouard philippe et horizons
n'a pas la même histoire que la
république en marche qui deviendra
prochainement renaissance et donc c'est
la plus la pluralité de ses parcours de
ces histoires de ces sensibilités qui
composent la majorité présidentielle qui
sont fait d'hommes et femmes qui ont
rejoint emmanuel macron à divers moments
de son cheminement politique avec une
volonté très claire de porter le plus de
députés possible à l'assemblée nationale
où moi je vois franchement on imagine
forcément le plus de députés renaissance
les besoins de renaître vous étiez mort
non nature paiement mais la nécessité de
non pas de
ripoliner la façade mais de créer un
nouveau parti politique un nouveau
projet politique au fond avec une façon
différente de travailler avec de
nouveaux visages avec des hommes et des
femmes qui seront peut-être plus
investis sur le terrain au plus près des
territoires et avec cette volonté de
continuer à faire venir à nous des
hommes et des femmes venus parfois de la
social-démocratie des écologistes
notamment qui ne se retrouvent pas dans
cette alliance contre nature formé à
l'extrême gauche aujourd'hui elsa vous
avez suivi tout ça de très près
l'objectif de cette conférence de presse
était aussi afficher l'entente c'est ça
de tous ces barons dont on a pu entendre
qu'avec certains notamment edouard
philippe il y avait de la tension
exactement franchement si on n'a pas
compris c'est vraiment qu'on avait mal
entendus ensemble ça a été répétée une
bonne quinzaine de fois tout va bien
c'était vraiment ambiance franche
camaraderie il ya eu aucun problème les
négociations se sont très très bien
passé on a fait un petit montage pour
vous montrer que vraiment c'était le
message politique à retenir aujourd'hui
tout cas les choses se sont déroulées
dans la bonne humeur ce sont les
négociations qui sont passés dans le
meilleur climat que j'aie jamais
rencontré et nous avons ensemble ouvrait
à trouver les conditions d'un bon accord
je crois que vous êtes tous trompés
parce que vous avez écouté des bavards
les bavards et d'une catégorie ce sont
ceux qui ne savent rien et qui parle
toujours
et nous étions en train de travailler ce
qui fait que ceux qui savent tous ne
parlent pas et
c'est ça la réalité du ensemble tout
sourire où il ya autre chose derrière la
fiche c'est la réalité du jour c'est
sans doute pas la réalité d'hier
évidemment oui on se tire un peu la
bourre pendant les négociations pour
arracher ici et là un siège avoir un peu
plus d'investiture que ce qui était
prévu bon ça s'est toujours fait y'a
rien d'inhabituel et ce sera peut-être
pas non plus la réalité de demain ou
après demain c'est à dire que là c'est
le plus facile on signe la paix des
braves on s'est mis d'accord demain il y
aura peut-être des mécontents parce que
ici tel proche de tel leader n'aura pas
obtenu son investiture elle voudra se
présenter en dissident et vice versa et
puis après demain ce sera
l'assemblée nationale et les textes de
loi qui devront être négociés entre les
entre les trois parties alors ça s'est
très bien passé faut le dire avec le
modem entre 2017 et 2022 on verra si ça
se passe aussi bien avec cette voie le
modem et horizons en 2022 liberté de
vote pour toutes ses sensibilités ces
groupes si il y à des groupes à
l'assemblée total y compris à dans
horizons la majorité sait c'est que ça
veut dire quoi juste qu'on est libre
dans cette confédération chacun est
libre dans une dans une dans un groupe
politique mais on a un mandat qui sera
très clair c'est de mettre en oeuvre le
projet pour lequel les françaises et les
français ont choisi de faire confiance à
emmanuel macron et donc le projet
comportera aux élections législatives
dans les semaines à venir c'est le
projet d' emmanuel macron et ensuite
nous auront vocation à mettre en oeuvre
à l'assemblée nationale ce projet pour
lesquels les françaises et les français
auraient fait confiance à un certain
nombre de députés après les jo quoi
qu'il en coûte mais après dans une
majorité qui puissiez loire compte les
différences de sensibilité l'ex qui
puisse y avoir des nuances sur certains
sujets ça existe et ça d'ailleurs
existait dans la majorité passé mais
avec la volonté toujours très claire de
ne pas bloquer le pays et de ne pas
empêcher la mise en oeuvre des réformes
et donc chacun peut exprimer des
sensibilités mais dans tous les moments
importants de la vie du pays vous pouvez
être certain que la majorité serait
extrêmement soudée on va venir sur cette
séquence qu'on appelle macron deux parce
qu'il ya les législatives et puis on a
on attend des nominations importantes
pour lancer cette campagne mais quand
même elsa je regarde ces images où sont
les femmes quel manque de femmes il ya
beaucoup de journalistes dans la salle
qui ont effectivement ticket en voyant
tous les chapeaux à plumes de la
majorité se sont tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps des hommes alors on
a posé la question à la fin de cette
conférence on nous a assuré qu'ils
allaient avoir évidemment de la parité
dans les députés et puis je pense qu'on
a bien conscience qu'il en manque sur la
photo et pourtant rien ne change vous
répondrais mais il ya un problème avec
au fond la question de partager c'est à
dire les lieux de pouvoir parce qu'on a
l'impression que oui est la parité dans
les textes mais les décideurs là où ça
se décide stratégiquement la fête
toujours les uns si on connaît mal
bellemare alors si on veut être honnête
si on prend les chefs de file des partis
de gauche
c'est aussi généralement des hommes voir
que des hommes mais à travers dans les
parcs en mariage ils ont une forme de
métier ou de de savoir-faire
communicationnel quand ils s'affichent
ensemble il faut toujours quelque chose
c'est qu'ils mettent pas seulement les
leaders fait on a aussi quelques porte
parole quelques vices présidentes qui
permet d'afficher bas une entente où il
n'y a pas que des hommes voilà c'est
c'est peut-être ça qui choquait
aujourd'hui c'est que voilà à choisir
quatre bars on n'y avait pas de femme
alors qu'il aurait peut-être
cette image franchement parce que quatre
hommes on pourrait presque voir ajouter
malblanc plus de 50 ans et cravate et
vous avez vous avez évidemment raison il
faut que toutes les toute la diversité
qui existe dans notre famille politique
puisse être représenté dans des moments
dans des moments importants mais je
rappelle quand même une chose c'est
cette majorité et c'est de cette famille
politique autour d' emmanuel macron qui
a fait la parité au sein de son groupe
politique on était premiers groupes
politiques à l'assemblée nationale avoir
une parité presque parfaite c'est ce
groupe qui a mis des femmes à la tête de
commission extrêmement importante à
l'assemblée nationale a restreint de
ceux qui prennent les décisions
politiques on se souvient du conseil de
défense sanitaire c'était frappant le
petit groupe autour du président
aujourd'hui
c'est votre analyse moi je partage pas
ce regard là parce qu'il ya des femmes
avec des responsabilités éminentes à
l'assemblée nationale et au gouvernement
qui entourent emmanuel macron au
quotidien elle veut dire barbara
pompidou ministre d'état numéro deux du
gouvernement c'est pas un petit c'est
pas un petit rôle au sein de la majorité
florence parly ministre des armées ce
n'est pas un petit rôle dans la majorité
et je pouvais faire une très longue
liste comme cela pour vous pour vous
montrer la place réelle et significative
des femmes dans cette agression de la
avec la volonté très claire dans la
majorité qui suivra si les françaises et
les français nous font confiance d'avoir
cette même parité à l'assemblée
m'arrêter la soci aussi de la
représentativité sociale sera pris en
compte dans les investitures on a été
frappé dans le premier mandat chez les
marcheurs très très très peu d'ouvriers
quelques agriculteurs une poignée oui
mais cette cette question de la présence
des six et sociale elle est pas propre à
la république en marche c'est un biais
que vous pouvoir trouver dans beaucoup
de partis politiques aujourd'hui même si
c'est vrai que d'autres formations
trompe peut-être plus en avance sur cela
mais la vérité que c'est que ça et ceux
qui sont arrivés à l'assemblée nationale
en 2007 autour d'emmanuel mâcon venaient
de milieux sociaux
des anciennes ont des infirmières des
avocats s'étaient c'était quand même
très variés et encore du travail à faire
pour faire revenir à la vie politique
des femmes et des hommes qui ont des
parcours différents mais ça on ne
travaille avec beaucoup de force etienne
avant d'avoir la liste voilà c'est au
téléphone nous permettent de regarder
rapidement le modem est plutôt bien
servi ça on a on a ce chiffre à environ
100 110 circonscription c'est plus qu'à
cinq ans oui il me semble qu'il ya cinq
ans on était autour de 75 absolument
donc c'est un plus pour le modem ils
sont en quelque sorte récompensés de
leur loyauté au cours du quinquennat
précédent c'est vrai qu'on peut pas dire
que le modem est cherché à mettre en
difficulté la république en marche à
l'assemblée nationale alors qu'à vers la
fin du quinquennat la majorité de la
république marche était moindre et donc
y aurait pu avoir cette tentation de
jouer sur cette capacité de nuisance ils
ne l'ont pas fait donc ils sont
récompensés aujourd'hui par plus
d'investiture qui a 5 ans l'autre
élément notable c'est que le modem a
plus d'investiture qu'horizon qu'
edouard philippe donc à une forme de
deux hiérarchies qui a été fait entre
les deux les deux alliés des manuels
mâcon a souligné rachid entre les alliés
à huy égalé de la première heure ils ont
pu vivre en paix mais pourquoi parce que
le modem a fait la preuve de sa loyauté
du côté d'horizon bon on préjuge plutôt
de cette loyauté parce que ça c'est ça
s'est bien passé quand edouard philippe
était premier ministre mais bahia qu'il
ya peut-être quelques incertitudes sur
les ambitions personnelles d'edouard
philippe pendant le quinquennat et donc
faire en sorte qu'il n'est pas trop de
députés donc un peu moins que le modem
bassa déplaisait pas manifestement
emmanuel macron et à la république alors
justement est là on va regarder horizon
le parti d'edouard philippe il n'est pas
humilier on peut le dire c'est important
peut-être de rappeler qu' il ya une
question subvention est une question de
financement très importante et ça je
crois qu edouard philippe a bien en tête
faut avoir au moins 50 candidats qui
dépasse je crois les 1% pour pouvoir
avoir ce financement là ils en ont 58
donc ça a priori c'est bon est-ce que
c'est mieux qu'espéré alors dans les
négociations on me dit tout le temps on
donne jamais chief parce que de toute
façon sinon on est perçu on est assurés
d'en avoir moins et on dit qu'on a perdu
la négociation mois de côté la
république en match on dit edouard
philippe en vous laissant donc c'est
perçu peut-être comme un moindre chiffre
après il faut savoir que 58 c'est quand
même suffisant pour avoir un groupe le
groupe edouard philippe il a déjà des
députés sortants en fait parce qu'il y
en a certains dans la majorité qui ont
déjà rejoint son parti horizon il y en a
une vingtaine donc là il peut être 15 1
pour un groupe pas exactement il peut
espérer alors il faut déjà que ces gens
là soient reconduits mais effectivement
il peut espérer avoir un groupe 58 pour
edouard philippe 110 pour le modem oui
on peut dire que les grands équilibres
sont respectées surtout qu edouard
philippe on dit beaucoup attention sa
popularité c'est pas son poids politique
c'est vrai mais l'at elle est très
grande soupe au poulet est d'accord à la
personnalité politique la préférée des
français pierre alexandre vandall dad il
fallait surtout pas humilier edouard
philippe c'était ça l'objectif après non
l'objectif c'était absolument pas ça
l'objectif était de trouver la juste
place d'edouard philippe dans la
majorité le directeur philippe a été
premier ministre de la france les chefs
de la majorité qui a mis en place de
grandes réformes souhaitées par emmanuel
macron dans ce dans ce premier
quinquennat il a mené la majorité avec
beaucoup de beaucoup de brio pendant
pendant plus deux pendant plus de deux
ans presque tous les ans quand tu es
donc bien donc gagnable à votre avis je
ne sais pas qui est investi ou non je
veux pas me risquer ce soir à faire un
pari et moi je suis convaincu qu edward
fini pour un groupe largement
conséquent dans la future assemblée vous
savez edouard philippe c'est un pilier
de la majorité c'est un pilier du
quinquennat qui vient de s'écouler on
lui doit des réformes importantes pour
le pays et moi je suis convaincu qu
horizon sera un pilier indéfectible de
cette majorité du modem et la république
en mars et unsa certes il aujourd'hui
politiquement quant à droite s'est
écroulé à 4% valérie pécresse au fond
cette fonction de passerelle dlr vers la
macro ni est assez fait d'elle-même est
ce que vous n'avez besoin véritablement
oui on a besoin mais edouard philippe
c'est pas une force d'appoint c'est
quelqu'un qui nous accompagnent
régulièrement de façon continue depuis
le début du quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron en 2017 à chaque étape importante
de la vie du quinquennat passé à chaque
crise importante il a été un soutien
infaillible du chef de l'état et donc
moi j'entends les petites musiques qui a
pu avoir ces dernières semaines mais
j'ai absolument aucun sur la loyauté la
fidélité d'edouard philippe au projet
comporte le pays avant de parler du
remaniement très très attendue dans les
les jours dans les semaines qui viennent
en tout cas pas plus tard que le 13 mai
prochain puisque c'est la fin de de ce
mandat macron un un tout petit mot sur
l'art m tous les sortants de se comparer
investi on a entendu parler de tableaux
excel avec des classements certains
députés sortants faible pas faible loyal
pas loyal moi je connais retard n'ont
pas fait de djabou le mois passé moi je
connais que des députés moi je connais
que des députés qui ont été investis du
début à la fin dans leur mandat
évidemment pour certaines et certains ça
a été difficile vous arrivez au palais
bourbon dans une nouvelle majorité sans
histoire politique commune parce que
c'était ça aussi notre réalité on
n'avait pas militer ensemble dans les
parties dionne on arrivait parfois
d'horizon politique extrêmement
différent entre la droite et la gauche
et la société civile et donc certains
ont trouvé leur place plus ou moins
rapidement et moi j'ai connu que des
femmes et des hommes qui ont mené leur
mandat avec beaucoup de sincérité
beaucoup de conviction donc on verra ce
qui sera la décision et la camaraderie
entre largeur mais ça on le savait ce
sont des noms mais c'est un mandat
exigeant le mandat de député c'est
difficile à l'assemblée nationale parce
que vous feriez avec vos opposition
c'est parfois difficile sur le terrain
parce que vous avez eu des grands
mouvements sociaux dans ce quinquennat
qui nous ont mis au défi est donc moi je
connais pas de député qui a été cassée
créé à l'assemblée ou qui sait des
investis localement donc moi j'ai
beaucoup de d'admiration pour celles et
ceux qui ont mené que le quinquennat
passé c'est comme ça qu'on voit les
choses en lieu on sait que c'est
emmanuel macron qui valait d'un lui même
chaque circonscription de ce que je sais
mais restons prudents je n'ai absolument
pas la liste des personnes investies ce
qui est envisagé c'est de réinvestir la
grande majorité des députés la
république aux marches qui souhaitent
mais oui c'est vrai il a été identifié
un petit groupe de députés qui n'ont pas
fait la faire pour des raisons x ou y
soit parce qu'ils ont été insuffisamment
loyaux faux parce qu'ils ont été mauvais
ça existe aussi et donc c'est ce petit
groupe là alors il y en aura quoi une
vingtaine oui cela ne serait pas
réinvesti alors en attendant d'avoir
cette liste si elle ne parvient en
direct le président de la république
réélu cherche toujours son premier
ministre jean castex va donc rester
jusqu'au bout étienne girard jusqu'au 13
mai c'est gabriel attal qui l'a annoncé
hier pourquoi est-ce si long alors
parce que j'ai même compris c'est qu'ils
emmanuel macron très clairement avait
proposé à jean castex de rester
jusqu'aux élections législatives le plan
d' emmanuel macron c'était de ne pas
changer de premier ministre et lui a
donné l'impression de vouloir partir
après les gens et jean castex a expliqué
que pour lui
il ne se sentait pas de diriger la
campagne des législatives en sachant
qu'il partira ensuite que lui était
plutôt enclin à ce que le premier
ministre soit changer dès le nouveau dd
que l'investiture la réinvestiture d'
emmanuel macron seraient effectués donc
pourquoi ça dure aussi longtemps en fait
c'est assez simple c'est parce que
emmanuel macron n'a pas choisi al avance
son premier il est encore en période de
réflexion et a pas trouvé long bail au
casting et voilà sur la personne et le
choix de cette personne évidemment eh
bien il se posera ensuite un jeu de
chaises musicales entre ces poids lourds
les poids lourds de son gouvernement est
donc une redistribution des rôles qu'on
va devoir attendre puisque tout
découlera de ce show car alexandre
anglade ce temps est ce que vous ne
croyez pas que voilà il peut vous être
reproché est ce que est ce que au fond
il ne joue pas un peu contre vous les
français attendent quelle équipe qui
pour matignon une femme à profil
écologique moi je ne crois pas je crois
que on est dans un temps où
les françaises et les français ont eu
lieu quelque part subi la campagne
présidentielle qui a été longue qui a
commencé très tôt pour certains
candidats qui a parfois été très
violente et qui a suscité un peu de
distance physique pour la politique de
la part d'une partie des françaises et
des français ça s'est matérialisée dans
le vote avec une abstention plus
importante que ce qu'on pouvait imaginer
par rapport à d'autres élections donc
moi je pense que ce temps nécessaire à
la respiration entre l'élection
présidentielle une nouvelle équipe et la
formation
élections législatives et à mon avis
nécessaire
de gauche vous savez prison la
république va être investi ouvrez
investi officiellement ce samedi le
quinquennat court jusqu'au 13 au capa
n'y a pas d'urgence voyait la rapidité
avec laquelle le commentaires politiques
et même l'ambiance politique dans le
pays évolue la gauche est revenue au
centre du débat politique alors qu'elle
avait été presque effacé pendant la
totalité de la campagne présidentielle
si ce n'est les dix derniers jours de
jean luc mélenchon était revenue un peu
sur le devant de l'actualité et donc là
un moment très fort pour cette alliance
contre nature qui s'en remet à gauche il
y aura d'autres temps jusqu'aux
élections législatives et donc à part ça
peut être assez tactique de vouloir au
fond prendre un peu de temps pour
réduire cette longue campagne mais elle
et elle est plus longue que d'habitude
des législatives elsa il ya quand même
des noms qui ont circulé apparemment
véronique b d'agde l'ancienne directrice
de cabinet de manuel valls a dit non
valérie rabault aurait dit non qui est
là qui étaient là président du groupe
socialiste à matignon finalement
matignon ça ce ça se refuse johanna
rolland la maire de nantes mickaël
delafosse le maire de montpellier ont
refusé de rentrer dans dans le
gouvernement mais il n'est pas capable
de convaincre ou alors même s'il porte
parole du gouvernement a redit plusieurs
fois que les propositions n'avaient pas
encore été fait dans ce sens non mais le
problème visiblement c'est aussi
défendre la réforme des retraites c'est
à dire qu'on recherche un profil
peut-être pour envoyer un message à
gauche sauf qu'en même temps il faut
défendre la réforme des retraites et ça
pour la gauche c'est très très difficile
alors c'est vrai que si on fait une
liste on cherche plutôt une femme plutôt
de gauche etc c'est vrai que prête à
défendre cette retraite cette réforme
des retraites ça fait très très peu de
noms sur la liste et l'équation à semble
un peu complexe bon je n'y crois pas
d'abord il faut il ya beaucoup de rues
il ya beaucoup de rumeurs sur des noms
de personnalités qui accélère tu aurais
accepté qu'il n'aurait pas accepté moi
je pense que tous ceux beaucoup parlent
sans savoir beaucoup se font aussi mou
c'est dans les médias pour laisser
penser qu'on leur a proposé quelque
chose sans qu'on leur ait réellement
proposé quoi que ce soit au gouvernement
voyons donc il faut prendre tous avec
beaucoup de distance et le présent leurs
élites la tuque a dit il faut que ce
soit une femme le temps des femmes est
venu y en a eu une depuis le début de la
vème république c'est aussi votre avis
mais moi je pense que je pense que si on
peut avoir une femme premier ministre
une bonne chose pour le pour le pays
effectivement vous avez aujourd'hui des
femmes en responsabilité dans toutes les
tous les grands postes de la république
donc pourquoi pas premier ministre après
il faut pas que ce soit une obsession à
tout prix vous savez c'est un poste
tellement fondamentale il faut aussi que
ça puisse marcher avec l'exécutif il
faut trouver la bonne personne au bon
endroit pour mener la campagne des
législatives donc oui moi si vous me
demandez si je souhaite que ce soit une
femme je pense que ce serait bien pour
la france maintenant il faut trouver le
profil qu'on vienne merci beaucoup on va
s'arrêter là merci d'être venu décrypter
ces investitures sur la scène
parlementaire merci pierre alexandre
survie anglade on va s'arrêter à présent
sur la situation en ukraine à la veille
des commémorations du 9 mai en russie
kiev accuse moscou de vouloir anéantir
les derniers soldats toujours retranchés
dans l'usiné azote ce talent de mario
paul la situation reste confuse dans cet
immense aciérie ultime poche de
résistance qui empêche les russes de
proclamer la victoire totale dans cette
ville du sud-est du donbass on va tous
vous voir tout cela en images avant
d'accueillir nos invités avec katia
guilde
ils sont les derniers combattants d'azov
stahl retranchés dans les souterrains de
lusine a siégé comme le montrent ces
images diffusées par le régime en
ukrainien azoff où on les entend chanter
fusil en main
aux côtés de ces soldats des civils
seraient toujours pris au piège
il y a encore des civils là bas des
femmes les enfants il faut du temps pour
sortir les gens de ses sous sols de ces
abris souterrains quelle est
la situation à obstacles et confuse la
propagande pro russe accuse kiev d'avoir
bombardé mercredi l' usine images à
l'appui invérifiable
de son côté moscou dément tout pilonnage
et affirme qu'un cessez le feu de trois
jours est en vigueur depuis ce jeudi
pour permettre l'évacuation des derniers
civils encore présent il n'y a pas de
dassault il y à des accrochages mais ils
sont dus aux combattants ukrainien qui
tente de sortir de l' usine eux ont
échappé au pire ils font partie des
quelques 300 civils évacués de lusine
dimanche grâce à un premier cessez le
feu après le passage d'une dizaine de
checkpoint ils ont pu rejoindre la ville
de zaporizhya 300 km à l'ouest de mario
paul plus à l'est les russes poursuivre
l'offensive dans le donbass dans la nuit
de mercredi à jeudi une trentaine de
civils ont été blessés dans le
bombardement d'un quartier résidentiel
de cramât torse qu moscou garde son
objectif numéro 1 relié le dombass en
partie contrôlée par les séparatistes
pro russes à la crim est annexée en 2014
mais la résistance fait face comme ici à
pâques rove skier ou des soldats
ukrainien tiennent leurs positions à 5
km de la ligne de front avant de
retourner dans les tranchées se protéger
des tirs de roquettes
ce jeudi le ministère russe de la
défense a déclaré avoir mis hors service
cigares en ukraine moscou affirme
qu'elle servait à acheminer le matériel
militaire fournie en masse par les
occidentaux sans donner plus de
précisions
bonsoir général train quant au soin et
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation aux chefs de la mission à
militaire française aux nations unies
bonsoir isabelle lasserre et 5 milliards
dans la lignée de cette émission
rédactrice en chef adjointe du service
international du figaro et ancienne
correspondante à moscou bonsoir stéphane
on sort mieux des fans bakowski qui
m'accompagne exceptionnellement dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission vous
allez nous parler de la date du 9 mai
date c'est lundi prochain dans des
terminaux ton juste après le week-end on
va partir de ces images et de la
situation dans le donbass général train
quand mario paul c'est une ville
quasiment rasé aujourd'hui on peut le
dire elle est devenue stratégique pour
poutine est ce que pour autant on peut
dire que sur l'ensemble de la région
l'offensive russe gagne du terrain
progressent ou les les positions sont
plus figées que cela non alors sur la
jonction entre la crimée il tomba mario
paul étant inclus les russes ont réussi
cette jonction il ya déjà eu un voyage
de presse organisé je croyais à trois
jours qui permettait de relier deux
de la russie à la crimée en passant par
cette bande de terre donc ça s'est fait
en revanche c'est dans le donbass où les
choses vont beaucoup moins vite
l'objectif des russes était d'encercler
en fait les forces de défense
ukrainienne qui sont depuis 2014 dans
cette zone est de percer il y a trois ou
quatre jours le temps passe je me suis
un puce et trois ou quatre jours le chef
d'état major de l'armée russe donc est
venue sur place pour regarder et pour
probablement définir si l'offensive aura
suffisamment progressé pour les quelques
jours qui restent
et puis de voir quel est l'axé parce que
souvent en fait la tactique russe était
assez simple on attaque sur trois ou
quatre axes on regarde qu'elle est là qu
ce qui progresse et on renforce le
succès et c'est comme ça que ça a été
fait je rappelle dans la période
précédente qui avait quatre axes y
compris kiev kharkiv et c est le seul
axe la carte du sud et donc ses vagues
sud qui a été préféré parce que c'est là
que ça a progressé mais tactiquement
aujourd'hui vous avez raison ça
progresse très très très lentement et
ceci est dû probablement à la difficulté
de réorganisation de l'armée russe
d'abord qui a fait quand même un grand
pour revenir de kiev jusque là il
fallait faire 1500 kg matin avec des
unités qui étaient prouvées et puis à la
grande résistance de l'armée ukrainienne
qui a un chronomètre dans la main la
date que nous avons cités mais également
l'approvisionnement en armement plus
l'approvisionnement arrive plus je vais
pouvoir résister parce qu'on a passé un
vrai tournant
isabelle les russes ne respectent pas la
trêve qui laisse prône qu'il promette
systématiquement à marioupol en tout cas
c'est ce qu'affirment les les ukrainiens
est ce que ça veut dire que malgré la
pression de l'onu des occidentaux leur
but est toujours de tuer des civils
la pression de l'onu organisé des
dossiers
à rien on a qu'à voir la manière dont le
secrétaire général des nations-unies a
été accueilli à kiev la dernière fois
par des bombardements russes vladimir
poutine n'a aucune estime pour les
nations-unies
et même tous ses efforts depuis très
longtemps consiste justement à
déconstruire l'ordre international issu
de la presse seconde guerre mondiale et
dans les nations unies sont le sont le
pivot donc les quant aux pressions
occidentales n'ont elles n'ont pas de
elles n'ont pas d'effet sur vladimir
poutine en tout cas pas ce type d'effet
est prêt lorsqu'il et les ja j'irai sur
le dossier humanitaire de l heure à
telle heure cette journée par marché au
bout de au bout de 10 jours mais vadimir
poutine veut être le seul à décider s'il
décide si c'est son intérêt d'ouvrir un
couloir humanitaire ou non et les seules
fois où ça a vraiment bien marché
souvenez-vous myriam c'était au début de
la guerre et parce qu'en fait les
ukrainiens là se sont fait avoir il a
ouvert des largement des couloirs faire
l'arrêt mais vers la russie en prenant
quasiment
d'aider des ukrainiens en otages fin
selon les russes les russes prétendent
je ne sais pas si c'est vrai à voir sur
leur sol un million d'ukrainiens
quasiment retenu prisonnier on sait pas
tellement les ans près pour la mémoire
accusé n'est évidemment pas là c'est
parce que c'est pas où ils sont deux
fonctions les laits et pour votre
question sur tirer sur les civils mais
oui c'est une des méthodes de l'armée
russe on l'a vu dans d'autres guerres en
syrie en tchétchénie et on l'a vu aussi
dans cette guerre au début quand les
russes ont tiré contre le théâtre de
mario paul la maternité de l'art dans la
rue paul est régulièrement quand ils
visent des civils qui sont en train de
s'échapper de des couloirs humanitaires
ça permet de créer la terreur et de
faire
monter la pression générale trinquant
sur la question de la livraison d'armes
et de quel matériel on a l'impression
qu'on a vraiment franchi un cap il y
avait un peu de lignes jusqu'à présent
les britanniques les américains qui
disait il faut livrer un maximum d'armes
écoutez et lenski de l'armement lourd
offensif et puis les européens tu as un
peu en retrait redire attention si on
livre trop ça va s'enliser ce conflit va
durer est ce que tout le monde est sur
la même ligne maintenant et est-ce qu'au
fond on n'est pas de fait devenu un peu
comme belligérants parce que cette
guerre on l'a fait un peu à distance
mais tout le monde livre de l'armement
puissant oui alors je voudrais rappeler
simplement que qui a eu trois phases et
eu la phase avant la guerre la guerre
qu'elle les américains les britanniques
et les canadiens en particulier étaient
très engagés dans la formation et dans
la livraison de l'armement donc avant la
guerre il y avait des livraisons d'armes
mais essentiellement missiles
antiaériens missiles antichars puis a eu
la phase de conflit trop souvent
les américains ça a commencé par sauve
qui peut je retire l'ambassade je retire
les conseillers et je demande au
président de l'unss qui si je peux aller
le chercher pour l'extraire
ça fait donc c'était un manque de
confiance dans ce qui allait se passer
et puis grâce à la résistance du
président vos années ce qui annonce ans
j'ai besoin d'un taxi mais de munitions
des ukrainiens qui ont re mind
remarquablement combattu tout a basculé
et là on a eu une graduation progressive
c'est à dire que y'avait pas de ligne
rouge c'était au président de poutine de
dire à quel moment ça s'arrêter et en
fait il a jamais tracé cette ligne donc
on a continué à approvisionner
d'armement aujourd'hui y compris la
france bien sûr même si c'est plus
compliqué d'acheminer l'armement alors
sur le cheminement de l'armement je
voudrais souligner était aussi là trois
phases la première c'est récupérer
l'armement russe
c'est paradoxal mais c'est l'armée russe
qui fournit le plus d'armements à
l'armée ukrainienne en l'abandonnant en
se faisant capturé aujourd'hui je crois
que c'est 250 à 300 chars qui ont été
c'est autant que l'armée française a mis
par les ukrainiens et cet armement et
utilisable tout de suite parce que c'est
d'armement que connaissent les
ukrainiens n'ont qu'ils avaient en
dotation donc ses armées russes qui a
fournit d'abord l'armement qui a permis
de ici tu es en partie ensuite ce sont
les pays d'europe de l'est ce bien avant
les américains qui en fournit europe de
l'est de l'union européenne
naturellement qu'ils avaient des stocks
d'armes qui datait de l'époque
soviétique est donc cet armement
toujours pareil c'est le même armement
il peut être utilisé tout de suite par
les ukrainiens et puis ensuite il ya
tout l'armement le reste alors les
américains avec leur canon de 155
les les allemands avec légué par les
canons antiaériens les panzers 2000 et
puis les français vous avez raison
l'aide d'un moment il n'ya pas aussi une
question de l'information j'ai
l'impression par exemple les ukrainiens
à battre le bateau mauvaise voie est ce
que c'est eux mêmes qui reperd ce bateau
ou est-ce que
le bateau ça c'est un autre sujet c'est
le renseignement si vous voulez en plus
l'impression que c'est une dimension
très important mais
évidemment vous me posez la question sur
le moment je vous réponds
sur l'armement évident sur les
enchaînements évidemment et les
américains dans deux domaines
d'abord il faut se souvenir qu'avant la
guerre les américains ont fourni les
renseignements se taire que le
renseignement est devenu de la
communication très important ça
n'existait pas dans mes mains et cannes
avant maintenant leur seulement devient
de la communication deuxième point vous
avez raison le renseignement tactique
fournies par les américains j'en donne
deux exemples la mort des fameux
généraux russes c'est quoi c'est ce
qu'on appelle du ciblage hier que les
américains arrivent à identifier ou et
le pc fournissent les informations aux
ukrainiens qui ensuite tape avec
l'artillerie sur les coordonnées qui ont
été fournis le moskva vous avez raison
il y avait un
avion de surveillance américains qui
étaient dans la zone et qui a
probablement fortis et du renseignement
qui a permis aux ukrainiens de tirer
avec leurs missiles à partir de la côte
donc le renseignement évidemment est
important
c'est une ligne rouge normalement ça
veut dire que poutine ne connaissons que
la force on a intérêt à le lui imposer
notre nos propres lignes rouges l'île
rouge pour qui pour les russes
normalement les virements oui là le
renseignement le ciblage alors toujours
plus lourd fait que la ligne rouge elle
adresse il dévient les rouches elles
peuvent d'abord on les dit pas toujours
ensuite quand on les dit on ne les
respecte pas toujours et puis elles
peuvent évoluer on ne sait pas vraiment
quelle est la ligne rouge de vladimir
poutine aujourd'hui c'est sans doute lui
qui valent à déclencher à un moment
donné à partir de quel moment
décidera-t-il
2 par exemple
détruire un convoi ou des bases
logistiques de des pays occidentaux par
exemple en pologne le fera t-il ou non à
partir de quel moment se sentir at il
suffisamment en difficulté avec un
risque de véritable défaite et d'une
victoire des ukrainiens pour par exemple
utilisé une arme tactique nucléaire
personne ne le sait les lignes rouges
occidental par définition on les connaît
tous en tout cas tout orient sur le
nucléaire en est une et vladimir poutine
lui c'est que le nucléaire en est une
dont vous voyez les lignes rouges barack
obama
avait parlé d'un million en syrie
respectez donc
alors justement on va parler du 9 mai
parce que l'agitation autour du
nucléaire on l'a entendu ces derniers
jours avec la vie des mires poutine en
quoi en quoi stéphane cette date elle et
elle est déterminante c'est lundi
prochain c'est crucial exactement là
aussi va célébrer donc la victoire de
l'urss fonctionnement la russie contre
l'allemagne nazie donc c'est une
victoire qui a quand même coûté
20 millions de morts en russie donc
c'est un événement beaucoup plus
considérables que ça peut être en france
et tous ceux qui ont discuté récemment
avec vladimir poutine vous le diront le
9 mai pour lui c'est une date fétiche
pour la russie le 9 mai est une date une
fête nationale un rendez-vous militaires
importants il est à peu près sûr que
pour le président poutine le 9 mai doit
être un jour de victoire et donc je
pense qu'ils vont concentrer leurs
efforts dans le nom basque
de fait c'est à peu près ce qui s'est
passé puisque on a vu que général nous
l'expliqué les efforts se sont
concentrés dans le sud et dans l'est et
aujourd'hui on a même depuis trois jours
trois quatre jours pris la ville de
marioupol qui résiste encore un peu
alors poutine va pouvoir revendiquer une
victoire avec ce discours lundi prochain
vous pensez le lisais ce matin que les
services secrets ukrainiens ne sont pas
mes intima vous doutez bien mais bon on
faisait ce week-end un faux comme quoi
vous qu'ils n'organiseraient bien une de
ces défilés de neuf semaines à marioupol
avec des images de propagande qui
montrerait koala et troupes russes ont
vaincu la question c'est de savoir s'il
peut se satisfaire d'une petite victoire
en fait parce que brasilia bah oui c'est
une manière de calmer le jeu on essaie
de consolider ses positions dans le sud
ou dans l'est on dit bah proposons une
fin du conflit
à condition bien sûr que les ukrainiens
accepte toutes nos conditions et si les
ukrainiens refusent dire ah bah oui
c'est de leur faute on était plein de
bonne volonté mais voilà
t'il vraiment prévu de calmer le jeu la
grande question cadors des journalistes
mais que se passe-t-il dans la tête de
vladimir poutine voulait déjà posé
j'imagine plus d'une fois tous les jours
et bien la semaine dernière un
journaliste anglais la pause et abengoa
la sq est donc le secrétaire d'état à la
défense britannique le ministre de la
défense lui a demandé mais d'après vous
quelles décisions vladimir poutine va
nous annoncer le lundi nas pernes écoute
je n'ai pas d'information particulière
mais je ne serais pas surpris que
poutine déclarant ce jour de mai nous
sommes maintenant en guerre contre les
nazis du monde et nous devons mobiliser
massivement le peuple russe dans les
cantons côté ambiance imagine plutôt qui
va renforcer son engagement dans le
conflit mobilisation donc engagement
dans la guerre plutôt qu'un vers saint
l'escaladent ça jusqu'où abbas frappe
nucléaire ça au moins on est on est au
courant depuis ce qu'ils appellent leur
appel dès le début poutine a bondi cette
menace mobiliser sa force de sidi de
dissuasion puis régulièrement l'on
brandit des tests d'essai fictif enfin
venue mais électronique à kaliningrad et
puis gré peut-être vu si vous l'avez pas
vu c'est le moment de la voir
la séquence à la télévision russe où ils
sont tout à fait enthousiaste aux
perspectives de frappe nucléaire
kaliningrad
maintenant il me tape ne touche pas car
ça c'est la télévision d'état russe faut
prendre ça au sérieux cette menace
alors je crois pas que barry sera règle
la carte lundi matin que vous avez
dentiste mardi je pense que c'est bon
c'est pas la peine d'un anglais en
revanche non mais ho dire qu'en fait à
la télévision russe avait un gars qui
avant disait que ce serait une
catastrophe donc ses grandes frappes on
n'y croit pas vraiment mais en revanche
dans la stratégie de l'armée russe il
n'est pas exclu quand un conflit
s'enlise d'utiliser des armes tactiques
c'est à dire de plus faible puissance
d'ailleurs le directeur de la cia et qui
s'appelle bill burns un vraiment
directeur de l'acier a dit il ya quinze
jours que son coup de la colère ce coup
de la frustration il pouvait pas écarter
l'hypothèse que poutine fasse appel à
ses armes nucléaires qu'on appelle
tactique et c'est une opinion qui est
partagé par les spécialistes en france
donc christian cambon qui est le
président de la commission de défense au
sénat qui disait ah je vois qu'il est au
sponsoring et on écoute quand même
rien exclu l'utilisation
d'armes excessivement destructrices
comme des missiles tactiques de deux
bassins de basse puissance et vous
pouvez envoyer une arme de 5 kilotonnes
ça fait cinquante ou cent mille morts
disons que ça change le sujet de nature
à vous connaissez la fascination des
journalistes pour le pire mais bon là ça
par son décor des experts qui
est
ce qu'il faut s'imaginer que c'est
possible vous avez vu qu'il ya une
simulation de tir de missile à capacité
nucléaire russe hier
premier point il faut quand on cite le
chef de la cia il faut le site et en
entier il dit je ne sais pas ce qui se
passe à la tête de monsieur poutine mais
la deuxième partie de la phrase et nous
n'avons aucun indice technique qui nous
montrent qu'ils préparent lusage de
l'armé nucléaire premier point deuxième
point sans écarter la possibilité mais
non mais évidemment la dissuasion c'est
ça
à présent
le président de la douma volodine
aujourd'hui à vallauris dit je rappelle
qu'il n'y a que les états unis qui ont
jamais utiliser l'armé nucléaire ce sont
les seuls qui ont dit qu'ils
utiliseraient en première action et nous
avons la capacité de réaction donc voyez
on tempère beaucoup donc si vous voulez
les shows télévisés qui s'adresse à la
population russe qui font monter un peu
la pression etc je n'y crois absolument
pas pour revenir en revanche au défilé
d'une heure on y vient voilà voilà
qu'est ce qui peut annoncer si on se met
dans cette hypothèse
d'une officialisation de la guerre à
l'ukraine ça change tout en fait pour la
société russe interdit oui elle est ou
sera officiel loi martiale mobilisation
générale conscrée jusqu'où alors le le
détail je ne sais pas mais le premier
point qu'on peut dire c'est que il va
s'adresser à la population russe
évidemment et donc une victoire croupion
comme
la jonction avec nos frères entre la
crimée le donbass étaient établis mario
paul a été conquise libéré par nom a été
libéré ça il pourra certainement dire
mais je pense qu'il va s'il veut grimper
d'un cran plus que d'aller au nucléaire
c'est sûr l'idéologique c'est sur les
valeurs c'est à dire que la russie est
au centre de la guerre mondiale contre
les pourris de l'autre côté dans les
valeurs sont pourris dont et cetera
c'est plutôt à ce niveau là il est
aujourd'hui si vous voulez là l'église
russe qui est associé d'ailleurs au
président poutine
ccc dans le domaine des valeurs je pense
plus qu'il va mener ce combat d'accord
avec ça oui
le fait de déclarer la guerre lui
permettra de mobiliser
à l'intérieur du pays et aussi dans la
communauté des états indépendants
il faut quand même et presser cette idée
auprès de l'être c'est faux leurs
homélies vous avez vu la propagande à la
télévision donc n'y a pas d'opposition
il n'y a pas de journaux d'opposition
donc voilà j'ai pas mal est réservé à
sion je n'ai pas est un gars il n'est
pas dit que ça marche c'est à dire qu'il
n'est pas dit que les que les soldats
russes se précipitent pour aller faire
la guerre contre leurs frères ukrainiens
mais je pense qu'il ya aussi de la même
manière qu il n'est pas dit que les pays
comme le kazakhstan ou l'arménie qui est
sans qu'un accord de sécurité avec la
russie qui pourrait si la guerre est
déclarée à l'ukraine en fait fournir aux
mêmes elle donne un coup d'éclat taillon
grand frère alors pas du tout on n'est
pas du tout certain que que ça marche se
met ça donc ça pourrait être contre
nantes ce nom ce message est aussi pour
moi à destination de l'occident c'est à
dire que c'est une housse est un moyen
supplémentaire de faire monter encore la
pression vis-à-vis de l'occident et ça
fait quand même
plusieurs semaines qu'on voit l'
escalade politique et idéologique est
aujourd'hui de plus en plus à peu près
un jour sur deux les responsables russes
passent leur temps à dire que le
problème à la limite c'est pas l'ukraine
mais c'est la nécessité de libérer le
monde entier du jeu occidental c'est à
dire que les russes sont en train de
développer un discours alors évidemment
ils disent pas le hêtre en guerre avec
l'occident ils prétendent que l'otan et
l'occident les attaquerons les
accusations à verser à la russie il faut
ça pour absolument tout dans le
microphone micro comme le maquereau mais
de plus en plus on a cette idée en
russie d'une d'une guerre entre
l'occident et le monde russes épaulés ou
aidé par ses parts par ses alliés et
c'est d'une certaine manière côté
américain aussi et joe biden
joba deuxième a dit qu'il s'agit bien
sûr évidemment celle qui dit qu'ils
agissent en ukraine concrètement d'un
combat de la démocratie
oui mais trop la taloche d'amour alors
si on déclare la gacilly poutine déclare
la guerre voyez bien que
psychologiquement on passe on passe à un
autre stade et cette guerre qui déjà
dans l'esprit des russes est une guerre
globale 3 le lva non mais ça me sort les
imaginaires
j'ai donc simplement pour poursuivre ce
que disait isabelle je pense que du côté
américain ce que vous disiez
souvenez-vous de la chercher quelles
étaient tes mais pas utilisés par le
président biden qui voulait une
coalition de
l'élection mais ça fait un flop
alors que là alors que là la guerre
permet de réunir ces démocraties et là
c'est comme c'est toujours pareil ce
sont les crises les guerres qui sont des
accélérateurs des phénomènes et réunir
45 pays autour d'une table pour parler
de l'avenir de démocratie tout le monde
s'en fout mais là je dis depuis le début
de la guerre depuis deux mois je dis que
la grande réussite de poutine c'est
qu'il a ressuscité le temps il a réuni
les européens et il a
réuni surtout les ukrainiens qui ne
croyaient pas qu'il pourrait fédérer une
partie du monde qu'on leur d'occident
parce que le sinon effectivement une
réputation qui exaspère dans nombreuses
parties du monde est ce que ça peut pas
alors en revanche vous avez raison de
souligner que je venais de des nations
unies j'étais sonné sur unis pendant un
petit moment
depuis 25 ans je vois que nos valeurs
démocratiques
occidentales ne sont pas partagées dans
le monde et là encore la guerre accélère
ce processus
on le voit bien aussi bien dans ceux qui
s'abstiennent lorsqu'on vote à
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
40 et quelques pays la moitié de la
population mondiale qui ne condamne pas
la russie et on le voit aussi dans ceux
qui n'appliquent pas les sanctions le
moyen-orient un certain nombre de pays
donc je pense qu'effectivement il ya ici
dans les crises un révélateur
survolez signer un nouvel ordre mondial
quoi c'est à dire que nous on a
l'impression de notre monde occidental
que le monde entier est contre vladimir
poutine et qu'il ne peut qu'être contre
vladimir poutine et sa sale guerre qui
mène en ukraine mais c'est un effet
d'optique c'est un miroir déformant il
ya une partie du monde grande partie du
monde qui soit soutien vladimir poutine
cesser les proches alliés genre
venezuela biélorussie en erythrée etc
soit qui sont dépendants économiquement
de la russie soit qu'ils sont liés par
un autre think par un anti
occidentalisme et par un anti
américanisme et qui se soude autour de
ce bloc qui essayent de constituer la
russie et la chine pour pousser un
contre modèle qui s'opposent au cordeau
modèle démocratique et libérale
occidentale hors vont-ils réussir je ne
sais pas mais c'est vrai que cette crise
a servi de révélateur on a vu d'un seul
coup que le monde était beaucoup plus
divisé qu'on a ce fait est que les
anciens les anciens blocs idéologiques
de la guerre froide sont en train de se
reposer il reconstitue réveiller d'une
certaine manière on va terminer rennes
reste une petite poignée de minutes avec
la réponse des occidentaux des européens
européenne notamment avec ce nouveau
paquet de sanctions sur la table des 27
sur cela von der leyen a présenté sa
volonté au nom de la commission
européenne est bien de se passer du
pétrole et non pas du gaz du pétrole
russe fin programmée écouter surtout des
ouïghours
en
chine
et non aux élections
générales train quand on n'y va pas à
pas
pour l'instant l'embargo sur le pétrole
ça peut taper poutine franchement
oui mais je crois qu'il ya surtout un
phénomène très très important sur cette
guerre qui va durer c'est l'unité de
l'europe et ça c'est essentiel de
maintenir cette unité de l'europe alors
là c'est une proposition de la
commission et on a vu tout de suite la
hongrie qui disait je ne
l'appliqueraient pas et s'est
montré l'exemple
la france est privilégiée dans cette
situation elle n'importe que
relativement peu il ya des pays qui
importe énormément il s'est beaucoup et
donc je pense que cette application
le il faut absolument
voilà d'une accord avec ça pourquoi la
france ne montre pas l'exemple mais ça
ne suis pas sûr super moche et je
remarque au début de la guerre il ya eu
vraiment une démonstration incroyable
unités européennes mais depuis quelques
temps je vois moi les fissures entre
l'est et l'ouest se reproduire et
notamment face à l'attitude américaine
c'est à dire que les polonais l'europe
orientale tout près du grand voisin
russe qu'il est bonne à son à fond pour
augmenter l'aide et comme joe biden en
rupture avec vladimir poutine alors que
les pays d'europe occidentale ont peur
d'être en camps ont peur d'être entré en
guerre il freine un petit peu alors
jusqu'où jusqu'où vont aller où ça et
l'europe elle se se divise elle se
ressoude baisser c'est ça ça va être le
dfid emmanuel macron dans les trois mois
de notamment qu'il reste de sa
présidence européenne avec un discours
on va en parler dans un instant avec
noah franche est attendu le 9 mai au sia
poutine et puis un bac ou à strasbourg
au parlement européen merci à vous deux
vous regarde avec moi un instant pour
vous faire réagir à nos chroniqueurs
merci merci à vous alors c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos a franchit donc ce soir
pour leur parti-pris richard wehrli qui
va se projeter sur le discours que
devait prononcer le chef de l'état lundi
9 mai à strasbourg et puis ce soir
vincent hugeux qui va nous parler du
mali ça va vous intéresser général train
quand le mali ou le torchon brûle que
jamais brûle plus que jamais avec
parinaud a franchi les voici bonsoir
messieurs bonjour merci d'être là on va
commencer avec vous richard alors on
sait que samedi c'est l'investiture avec
cet événement un peu particulier pour le
président emmanuel macron réélu mais
vous nous dites au fond la véritable
investiture s'est pas samedi où il
recevra le le la grande croix de
chevalier de donneurs c'est à de grand
maître de l'ordre de la légion d'honneur
de la légion d'honneur merci de me
corriger mais ce sera lundi au parlement
européen pourquoi et bien effectivement
ce sera le 9 mai qu'emmanuel napperons
va s'exprimer au parlement européen à
strasbourg alors déjà il y à ces dates
le 7 mai vous l'avez lu vous l'avez dit
l'investiture il ya le 8 mai la
cérémonie de commémoration de la
victoire et il ya le 9 mai on vient d'en
parler je l'entendais à propos de moscou
et a strasbourg c'est très important car
si vous vous souvenez myriam de cette
soirée du second tour le 24 avril au
pied de la tour eiffel il y avait une
manuelle macro mais qu'est ce qu'il y
avait comme toujours quand emmanuel
macron se déplacent des drapeaux
européens bleu étoilé c'est sur l'europe
il faut bien le dire c'est sur son
arrimage européen qu'il s'est en partie
fait réélire c'est sans doute l'élément
le plus fédérateur de son électorat
alors emmanuel macron c'est sans doute
ce qu'il va dire il va reparler de
souveraineté européenne ça résonne
particulièrement avec l'ukraine il va
reparler d'autonomie stratégique de
lieux là on peut en douter vu la
situation ça semble quand même compliqué
il a vraiment fait de ces sujets
européens sa marque présidentielle ce
sera l'objet de ce discours à strasbourg
qui en plus intervient le jour de la
fête de l'europe c'est-à-dire
l'anniversaire du discours du 9 mai 1950
de robert schuman un jour pendant lequel
il y aura pas mal d'activités en france
et ce samedi à paris par exemple il ya
la fête de l'europe sur le parvis de
l'hôtel de ville alors l'europe elle est
évidemment au coeur de son mandat mais
il s'exprimera aussi comme le pays d'une
puissance vous l'avez peut-être remarqué
mais le 7 mai il y aura un détachement
de l'aviation duclair stratégiques
françaises qui sera convié à l'elysée
c'est quand même un signal c'est de
rappeler que la france est une puissance
nucléaire
quand il y aura une forte de com de
réponse vous pensez ce jour là depuis la
capitale européenne au président russe
oui je voudrais revenir sur un point sur
lequel vous et métiers des doutes c'est
à dire l'autonomie stratégique
je pense qu'il faut que les européens se
souviennent qu aujourd'hui nous
travaillons avec l'otan et grâce au
bouclier de le temps on se protège
contre une menace russe
avec les américains très engagé
qu'en sera-t-il dans trois ans si
l'administration américaine change et ça
il faut le garder à l'esprit parce qu'on
a trop tendance à prendre pour argent
comptant que les âmes un gay rytas
engageons je rappelle qu'on a une
administration mec
dit exactement le contraire donc il faut
garder ça c'est à dire que cette unité
européenne avec les américains doit
révéler aux européens qu'il faut
absolument qu'il grimpe en gamme pour
que si les américains n'étaient pas à
côté d'eux hills et 7 ne te nomine
stratégique qui leur manquent jusqu'à
maintenant et à l'euro et après il y
aura après le 9 mai à strasbourg il y
aura le voyage en allemagne le dîner
avec olaf scholz et ça c'est très
important vous avez remarqué que
l'allemagne était directement visé par
les deux principaux adversaires des
manuels macron marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon éléments premier voyage
officiel du président réélu alors il
nous reste un peu de tout ça va vous
intéresser général trinquant pour parler
du divorce franco malien s'avoue
chroniquer ce divorce vincent depuis des
mois déjà mais nouvel épisode les
accords de défense accords militaires
scellé avec paris depuis 2013 ont été
rompues pas vraiment une surprise
vraiment pas tant la dégradation des
relations franco malienne était devenue
patente en mai dernier sur fond de
confiscation par la junte parvenu aux
commandes étaient précédent de tous les
leviers de l'exécutif quoique parer
d'atours juridique tailler à la hache la
décision est à l'évidence politique au
passage il ya quelque chose de baroque
dans le légalisme pointilleux qu'invoque
une un pouvoir putschiste dénué de toute
légitimité passons une certitude le
colonel assimi goïta et son orchestre
ont choisi d'évincer les gaulois au
profit des mercenaires de la société
russe wagner que l'on s'est inféodée au
kremlin un épisode d'anthologie aura
cristallisé le contentieux le 21 avril
l'état major français diffuse les images
tournées par un drone aux abords du camp
de gossip rétrocéder l'avant veille aux
forces maliennes on y voit des gaillards
au teint pâle wagnérien en diable
recouvert de sable des cadavres puis
filmer les corps à demi ensevelies et ce
peu avant que bamako annonce la
découverte d'un charnier laisser dans
leur siège en croire les réseaux pro
russe le cobp bien sûr par les soldats
de l'opération anti djihadistes barkan
on a vu des mises en scène un chouïa
plus sophistiqués alors sur le terrain
qu'est ce que ça change cette rupture
précipiter dans les faits à ce stade pas
grand chose tout démontage d'un
dispositif aussi lourd s'apparente à un
marathon doublé d'un cauchemar
logistique le désengagement annoncée dès
février par l'elysée s'achèvera au mieux
au coeur de l'été on ne peut pas en
réduire la durée par décret et moins
encore par oukase à cet instant il y
encore plus de 2000 soldats français sur
le territoire malien et sur le fond en
revanche l'impact d'un tel divorce ne
saurait être swiss mais bien sûr le
niger voisin accueillera des unités de
forces spéciales déployées par ses
partenaires étrangers est appelé à
épauler son armée mais quid de la minus
ma la mission des nations unies au mali
soit quatorze mille casques bleus et
policiers désormais privée du soutien
précieux fournis par barkan et dont le
mandat au passage expire en juin une
mission qui d'ailleurs celui-ci 120
l'autorisation d'enquêter sur le carnage
commis fin mars à mucha dans le centre
du pays deux sans trois terroristes
neutralisés au dire de bamako environ
300 civils exécutés sommairement par des
bidasses malien et leurs camarades russe
selon les ong human rights watch la
france dans tout ça n a rien à se
reprocher dans ce processus de rupture
et de pourrissement ce serait trop
simple jean yves le drian le patron du
quai d'orsay où la ministre des armées
florence parly aurait pu faire
l'économie de propos inutilement
acrimonie il aurait dû déjouer le piège
de l'escaladé rhétorique mais au fond là
n'est pas l'essentiel
si les galonnés bamakois imagine qu'il
suffit pour terrasser litres djihadistes
de substituer à barkan les soudards de
wagner moins performant au combat que
dans les exactions et le pillage et bien
ils s'exposent à de cruelles déconvenues
la junte s'enfonce hélas dans les
ténèbres du mensonge l'envoûtant mali
les maliennes et les maliens va le mieux
mérite mieux que cela
cette rupture consommée alors qu'ils y
d'aider des écarts de langage peut être
certainement mais si vous voulez le le
coup d'état dans le coup d'état au mali
à régler le problème français à
l'évidence les
officiers qui s'entendait bien avec
l'armée française qui est quand même
depuis huit ans aux côtés de l'armée
malienne en soulignant que c'est la
france qui paye pas le mali alors que
pour wagner c'est le mali qui paye il
faut faire cette différence
est donc
ont été évincés par le chef de l'état
temporaire putschistes etc
permettez moi de faire le lien avec la
crise dont nous parlions avant le cren
les wagnériens se comporte comme l'armée
russe abuja de la même façon et donc
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on voit sur la place
de ma vinco des gens d'essayer de payer
avec des drapeaux russe mais qui sont
payés par la russie pour dire les
français dehors on ne va pas regarder à
gocité sa lite ou ailleurs les maliens
qui pleure du départ des français et
pour revenir sur le dé la minus ma vous
avez raison de le souligner le
secrétaire général des nations unies
étaient présents dans l'ouest et ils en
parlaient et il disait on a des
difficultés de plus en plus grande avec
le gouvernement malien et le paradoxe
est que l'armée malienne qui a été
attaqué il ya quelques jours demandé
l'aide de la minus mas qui elle-même
demande l'aide de barkan donc
oui les 15 secondes pour simplement pour
dire que ici même il ya deux semaines
j'ai évoqué l'un des phénomènes les plus
fascinants du moment c'est la
poutinisation de la jeune malienne
jusque dans le lexique et la sémantique
à une enquête officielle merci beaucoup
merci les affranchis merci général de
racan d'être venu sur le plateau de lcp
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
vous de nous avoir regardé la chaîne
youtube pour voir ou revoir cette
émission tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire et j'apprends à l'instant
via mon rédacteur en chef qui me parle
dans cette oreillette que 187 députés
ont été réinvestis pour la nouvelle
formation de la majorité ensemble on va
y revenir sur l'axé fait bien évidemment
très belle soirée et puis c'est clément
méric vous retrouverez demain à la
semaine prochaine quand même
[Musique]